MORE AND FOLLOWING ALL OF THE
DETAILS OUT OF ANNAPOLIS,
MARYLAND IN OUR BREAKS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
FOR OVER A YEAR HOUSE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
AND INVESTIGATE HOW THE FBI AND
THE DOJ HANDLED THE CLINTON
SERVER INVESTIGATION.
FISA ABUSES.
THEIR EFFORTS DOES THEIR
SUBPOENAS, THEY HAVE BEEN MET
WITH NOTHING BUT OBSTRUCTION AND
HATRED FROM THE DEPUTY AG, ROB
ROSENSTEIN.
SOME OF THESE HOUSE MEMBERS HAD
A RARE OPPORTUNITY TO HOLD
ROSENSTEIN ACCOUNTABLE RIGHT TO
HIS FACE.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
BOB.
>> RECENT GENERAL'S REPORT
REREALED BIAS IN THE TOP OF THE
FBI DURING THE HOTLY CONTESTED
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IT REVEALED THAT FBI AGENTS,
LAWYERS AND ANALYSTS HELD
OPPONENT HILLARY CLINTON.
IT IS RIGHT OUT OF A NOVEL WITH
SALACIOUS UNVERIFIED DOSSIERS
AND INFORMANTS THAT APPEAR MORE
LIKE SPIES FOR THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND SURVEILLANCE
POWERS TO COLLECT ON A U.S.
PERSON ASSOCIATED WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
IT'S NOT A NOVEL.
IT'S REAL LIFE.
>> Sean: NEXT THE ILL TEMPERED
HE WAS GRILLED BY THE OHIO
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN OVER
ROSENSTEIN'S EFFORT TO HIDE
IMPORTANT INFORMATION FROM HOUSE
INVESTIGATORS.
THERE IS THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
JOB.
OVERSIGHT AND SEPARATION OF
POWERS.
CO-EQUAL BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
LOOK AT THIS TENSE EXCHANGE.
>> WHY ARE YOU KEEPING
INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS?
>> I AM NOT KEEPING ANY
INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS.
>> MR. ROSENSTEIN, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WOULD SAY
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT THEY
WILL SAY.
ON RECORD SAYING YOU HAVE NOT
COMPLIED WITH REQUESTS FROM
YOU HAVE NOT COMPLIED WITH
SUBPOENAS.
YOU HAVE 7 DAYS TO GET YOUR ACT
TOGETHER.
THAT'S NOT JIM JORDAN.
I THINK THAT'S THE MAJORITY OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
IN JUST A FEW MINUTES I THINK
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU WON'T GIVE
US WHAT YOU ASK FOR.
>> I HOPE YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE
NOT UNDER THAT IMPRESSION.
THAT'S NOT ACERALITY.
>> IT IS ACCURATE.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, ALLOW THE
WITNESS TO ANSWER.
>> Sean: THE HOUSE DID , IN FACT
PASS A RESOLUTION DEMANDING THAT
THEY DO FACE THE POSSIBILITY
FIRST OF CONTEMPT AND EVEN
IMPEACHMENT.
THE PRESIDENT CAN DEMAND
EVERYTHING BE HANDED OVER AND
THAT WILL BE A MATTER OF LAW.
IN TERMS OF THE PRESIDENT HAVING
THAT POWER.
POSSIBLE COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
FBI'S INITIATION OF THAT TRUMP
RUSSIA WITCH HUNT.
ONE OF THE SMALL PART OF THE
SCANDAL SURROUNDS BRUCE DOES
FOR THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
REMEMBER FUSION GPS WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
ALL WHILE HER HUSBAND BRUCE,
A HIGH RANKING DOJ OFFICIAL WAS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S POINT
OF CONTACT FOR THE SAME
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
ROB ROSENSTEIN IS SAYING HE WAS
TOTALLY UNAWARE OF THE
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU SAID EARLIER, BRUCE ORWAS
NOT WORKING ON THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
>> TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
STEELE, GETTING THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE DOSSIER AND SUPPLYING
THAT INFORMATION TO THE FBI AT
THE SAME TIME HIS WIFE WAS
WORKING WITH FUSION GPS WHO WAS
HELPING HILLARY CLINTON.
YOU DID NOT KNOW HE WAS DOING
THAT FOR THE FBI?
>> CORRECT.
THE GO BETWEEN TO GET THAT
ASKED BY FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
DESANTIS:
WHY HASN'T ROB ROSENSTEIN
RESCUED HIMSELF FROM THE MUELLER
WITCH HUNT?
A LOT OF WHAT YOU ARE HEARING
SHOULD BE RECOGNIZABLE TO YOU.
WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING THIS FOR
A LONG TIME.
IT WAS ALL TRUE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU APPOINTED MUELLER.
YOU ARE SUPERVISING MUELLER.
AND COLLUSION BETWEEN TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA AND
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, BUT YOU
WROTE THE MEMO SAYING COMEY
SHOULD BE FIRED AND SIGNED THE
FISA EXTENSION FOR CARTER PAGE.
SO YOU SHOULD BE RESCUED MORE
PRONGS OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU DONE THAT?
>> I CAN ASSURE YOU, IF WERE
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO RECUSE I
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY.
BUT IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
IT.
>> THEN HOW DO YOU HAVE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
POSSIBILITY FOR A PRESIDENT
EXERCISING HIS POWERS TO FIRE AN
FBI DIRECTOR THAT YOU SAID
THE MUELLER PROBE?
>> SIR, I AM NOT COMMENTING ON
WHAT IS UNDER INVESTIGATION BY
>> Sean: 407 LONG DAYS INTO
MUELLER'S FISHING EXPEDITION.
CONGRESS GOWDY CONFRONTING ROB
ROSENSTEIN WITH WHAT WE HAVE ALL
BEEN THINKING.
COUNTRY.
THEY SHOULD BE THE TARGET.
RUSSIA IS NOT HURT BY IT
INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE.
THIS COUNTRY IS BEING HURT BY.
IT WE ARE BEING DIVIDED.
WE HAVE SEEN THE BIAS.
WE NEED TO SEE THE EVIDENCE.
IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE OF
WRONGDOING BY ANY MEMBER OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, PRESENT TO THE
DAMN GRAND JURY!
IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY,
PRESENT IT TO THE AMERICAN
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED.
WE ARE ALL BEING DENIED.
WHATEVER YOU'VE GOT FINISH IT
APART.
>> Sean: THAT'S RIGHT.
MUELLER AND WEISSMAN.
ARE YOU WATCHING WHAT YOU ARE
DOING TO THE COUNTRY?
ROB ROSENSTEIN, WHEN DOES THIS
WITCH HUNT END?
ROD ROSENSTEIN IT'S YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO PROVIDE
CHECK YOUR DEPARTMENT.
IN 7 DAYS FROM TODAY, IF THE DOJ
CONTINUES THIS OBSTRUCTION, I
URGE EVERY MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
TO TAKE ACTION TO MOVE TO
CONTEMPT AND YES IMPEACHMENT.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
GOWDY WAS RIGHT.
MANY DEMOCRATS ARE FINE WITH THE
DOJ OBSTRUCTION.
THEIR FRIENDS IN THE DEEP STATE
HAVE A LOT TO HIDE.
ROBERT MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT HAS
PRODUCED ZERO EVIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID ANYTHING WRONG.
THE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT ARE
BEGINNING TO UNRAVEL.
THEIR FAVORITE NEW TARGET:
THE U.S. IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOM
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY DOING THE JOB
THAT CONGRESS PASSED.
THROUGHOUT THE WEEK HUNDREDS OF
LEFT WING PROTESTORS OCCUPIED
ICE OFFICES FORCING SOME TO
TEMPORARILY CLOSE THEIR DOORS.
THE DEMONSTRATORS BLOCKED
ENTRANCES AND ATTEMPTED TO
CAMPOUT IN FRONT OF THE
BUILDING.
THE HILL REPORTED MANY
PROTESTORS CELEBRATED THE NEWS
THAT THEIR OCCUPATION PROMPTED
DELAYS IN OPERATIONS AT THE
CENTER.
THIS MAY RESULT IN SOME
GREAT JOB.
THIS ENDED TODAY IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. WHERE 575 PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED AFTER STORMING THE
SENATE BUILDING.
LAWMAKERS WERE IN ATTENDANCE
INCLUDING ONE CONGRESSMAN FROM
WASHINGTON WHO WAS ARRESTED.
THIS ANTI-ICE RHETORIC FROM THE
LEFT ON TV IS EVEN FAR WORSE.
WATCH THIS.
>> I THINK THERE IS NO QUESTION
SCRATCH.
>> WE NEED TO ABOLISH ICE.
THEY HAVE STRAYED SO FAR FROM
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THE INTEREST OF
HUMANITY.
>> ICE IS BEING USED AS ITS OWN
PERSONAL POLICE FORCE AND MAKING
US LESS SAFE.
>> Sean: THE LEFT DEMOCRATS IN
THIS COUNTRY WANT TO ABOLISH
ICE.
THIS ELECTION IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT MID-TERM IN YOUR LIFE.
IF DEMOCRATS WIN THIS NOVEMBER,
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE PUSHING
FOR.
I HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP.
DON'T TELL ANYBODY.
THEY ARE SAYING PUBLICLY THEY
WANT TO REPEAL THE TRUMP TAX
CUTS AND RAISE YOUR TAXES.
AND THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY DON'T WANT A WALL.
AND NUMBER 5, THEY WANT TO
DESTROY WHOEVER THE PRESIDENT 56
PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NO AGENDA, NO
REAL PLAN TO IMPROVE THIS
COUNTRY AND HELPING THE
PREDICTABLE.
A CAMPAIGN TO SMEAR AND
ASSASSINATE THE CHARACTER OF ANY
TRUMP REPUBLICAN.
WE SAW THIS AFTER JUSTICE
KENNEDY ANNOUNCED HIS RETIREMENT
AS I PREDICTED LAST NIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF YOU ARE LGBTQ, OR A PERSON
OF COLOR OR A WOMAN.
WHEN YOU ARE NOT A STRAIGHT
WHITE MALE IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW,
YOU ARE PROBABLY FREAKING OUT.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> CLEAN AIR AND WATER WHAT YOU
USE AND BREATHE IS AT STAKE.
>> YOU ARE ONLY 81!
>> [LAUGHING].
THEY SAY 81 IS THE NEW 79.
DON'T TELL ME YOUR MIND IS
GOING.
I READ BUSH VERSUS GORE AND
CITIZENS UNITED.
YOU NEVER HAD ONE.
>> WE ARE LOOKING DOWN THE
TUNNEL OF CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR
WOMEN WHO ARE SEEKING TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR OWN
DOWN.
DONALD TRUMP AND REPUBLICANS ARE
PLAYING BY STREET RULES.
WE NEED TO PLAY BY STET RULES.
>> Sean: I TOLD YOU.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S BAD.
IT GETS WORSE.
LOOK AT THIS DISTURBING IMAGE
FROM THE HOVINGTON POST.
THIS IS DISTURBING.
A CLOSE HANGER WITH THE WORDS OF
THE END OF ROE.
OVER AT THE "VIEW."
ANOTHER VIEWER WARNING.
WHAT YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE AND
HEAR IS GRAPHIC.
>> I DON'T LIKE THIS LINE, I AS
A DEMOCRAT OR WHATEVER IS TRYING
TO TAKE AWAY ANYTHING FROM YOU.
I AM TRYING TO HOLD ON TO MY
PERSONAL RIGHTS SO YOU HAVE THE
RIGHTS YOU WANT.
IF YOU TAKE MINE, I FEEL LIKE
YOU ARE THE ONE WITH THE
PROBLEM.
YOU TAKE MY RIGHTS AWAY FROM ME
TO JUDGE WHAT I DO WITH MY BODY,
I HAVE A LITTLE PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO TAKE
YOUR GUNS.
GET OUT OF MY BEHIND AND MY
VAGINA.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA LYING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE SAME TACTICS THE LEFT USED
AGAINST PRESIDENT REAGAN.
THE SAME KIND OF SMEAR CAMPAIGN
USED AGAINST JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
HASN'T NOMINATED ANYBODY LEFT.
YOU BETTER BELIEVE THE TACTICS
FROM THE LEFT WILL GET WORSE
EVERY DAY FROM NOW TO ELECTION
DAY.
HOLD ON TIGHT.
BUCKLE UP.
AND YEAH, YOUR VOICE NEEDS TO BE
HEARD IN NOVEMBER.
WE WILL TELL YOU ALL OF THE KEY